[Applaudissements]
également il joue actuellement avec cet
artiste rachid dallas merci à la puce
qu'un plus qu'un artiste une légende
d'ailleurs un mythe
alors il va nous faire une troisième
chanson 2010 c'est un problème il a des
petits problèmes de moustapha niasse est
la même en dessous
bon je me suis rangé ses ventes se raser
la moustache doc rachid dallas vous fait
découvrir des séries télé en chantant
ils jouent avec leur est actuellement
elle en est à 2 sur 2 est ce qu'il peut
nous enterrer un troisième oui c'est
possible s'est passé parce c'est
précieux c'est parti
c'est une série scientifique
qui a lieu aux usa
leurs lampes le c'est magique il trouve
du spel elle-même quand y'en a pas
ils sont six
ils roulent pas miami à new york sans
lara cinq fois par jour sur tf1 je crois
mais c'est des flics ils ont la cclat
surtout présent avec son petit ami
[Musique]
là
le belge est battu vous avez remarqué
chez vous quand il finit sa chanson il
ya ce petit geste ake pa mal vie qui
fera un essai on a l'impression qu'il a
un carré plongeant mais en fait non
l'expert experts je vais pour la peau du
traître effort massif dallas et globaux
est dédié à tous merci
[Musique]
bonus